... what does Black Widow do?
You know she's not working at the Gap part-time.
I don't know that.
How do superheroes in the MCU earn a paycheck?
Nina?
No, you know what?
I'm going to toss this one to Tom first.
Tom?
If you're sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
So the way that I see it, there are three
different ranks of superheroes in the MCU.
Right.
You get your A-listers, your B-listers, and
your C-listers.
Does that seem accurate?
Okay.
So at the bottom rung, I think what you've
got is you've got guys like White Vision.
The ones that nobody's super familiar with,
but they all know that he's around.
I think those guys are mostly doing Grubhub.
Okay.
So after that...
They're just Postmates delivery drivers.
100%.
Yeah.
No, they've got jet packs, they've got motorcycles
and stuff.
They do okay.
They're probably pulling 30% more deliveries
than your average driver.
So they're making more than minimum wage,
they're doing fine.
But at the same time, it's always weird because
they show up at the door and they're like,
hey, this is teriyaki for to go.
They're like, oh, you're what's his name.
He's like, White Vision.
And they're like, oh, from the...
I can't remember what.
He's like, it's fine.
So you got that guy.
Okay.
So B-listers, I think those are the guys that
are going to...
So you've got War Machine, guys like that.
They're all doing cameo.
And they're all right.
It keeps them busy.
Really, it's more comfortable than most people
have any right to be.
You work two days a week, you pump out 17
or 18 of these things a day.
You're fine.
You're doing okay.
Now there are also the A-listers, but before
I get to that, I think that there's an in-between
with the B-listers and the A-listers that
I think we need to address, and that's Hawkeye,
I think Hawkeye tells everybody that he, and
this is just based on his haircut from Endgame.
I think he tells everybody that he's doing
really well trading Bitcoin, but in reality,
he's on cameo too.
And he's charging less than Ernie Hudson.
Or he's selling his belongings on eBay.
There's probably a little bit of memorabilia
stuff.
Yeah.
This was in the same room as Captain America,
this was in the same room.
This is something I stole off Iron Man's suit.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No, that's what it is.
He's going through people's lockers when they're
not at work.
And he's like, yeah, who wants Loki's Tic
Tacs?
I'm pretty sure they're Loki's, I found them,
they were on the ground close to where Loki
was also on the ground.
So there's an argument to be made that these
are $500 Tic Tacs.
So I think that that's what he's doing.
And then A-listers, that was a problem for
me.
I was trying to figure it out.
And then I remembered there's that line in...
It's in Captain America and the Winter Soldier.
Where Captain America gets into the elevator
and then all the guys pile in after him.
And Captain America says, "Before we start,
does anybody want to hear about MeUndies?"
So endorsements.
They're all natural and they're three times
as absorbent as cotton.
MeUndies, the underpants that a postal worker
has to hand to you.
So yes, I think it's endorsements.
I think that the A-listers are all...
And we see a little bit of it with Captain
America in Homecoming where he has to do...
He's doing the public service announcements.
There's no way that he's not making at least
scale doing that.
I mean, we can agree.
Those are my theories.
Okay.
Very good.
Now we should, before we continue, we should
establish why we're even asking this question,
right.
Because in Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
Anthony Mackie's character, Sam Wilson, the
Falcon, the new Captain America goes to a
bank, and like the Human Torch from Anchorman,
was denied a bank loan.
And he says, the bank officer is like, well,
aren't you...
Does Stark give you money?
And he's like, it doesn't really work that
way.
And he says, I got government contracts, but...
And then he kind of trails off.
And so that's what got us thinking about,
okay, so if you're on the Avengers, how do
you make money?
Right.
What happens?
Nina, did you have any thoughts about this?
Well, another nearly as clever as Tom's ranking
of Postmates delivery to podcast endorsements.
I mean, there's the obvious ones, right-
Don't hold yourself to that standard.
There's the obvious ones with we know how
Tony Stark made his money.
Right.
He ran Stark Enterprises, I know he stopped
selling weapons, but he is this tech wiz who
can create and sell basically anything in
the world.
So there's that.
And I got the sense that Captain Americas,
through time, are subsidized by the US government,
especially as we got into Falcon and the Winter
Soldier.
But yeah, I really struggled with what does
Black Widow do.
You know she's not working at the Gap part-time.
I don't know that.
And so it's just-
She might.
She's undercover.
Okay, fine.
Maybe she folds khakis.
I have no idea.
But yeah, because these are some of the most
recognizable people in the world, so how would
they hold a regular job.
And also, most regular jobs don't let you
leave for weeks at a time to go squash a Hydra
uprising in some far-flung European country.
Right.
Most jobs aren't like, yeah, you can have
a month off to go fight Thanos.
Right.
Because with Black Widow specifically, you
brought up Black Widow.
We saw at the beginning of Avengers and in
Iron Man that she worked for S.H.I.E.L.D.,
and so obviously she was getting a paycheck
that way.
But then in Captain America and the Winter
Soldier, S.H.I.E.L.D.
disbands.
And so she's obviously not going to earn a
paycheck that way after that.
So yeah, you raise a good question.
How is she paying the rent?
I mean, maybe we'll find out in the Black
Widow movie, but it seems unlikely that they're
going to cover that particular...
Right.
So either every kind of non-subsidized person
has some enormous family inheritance that
they're just still working through.
But that's unlikely.
And I guess the only other one where I'm like,
I know how he has a brownstone in New York
is Dr. Strange because he was a neurosurgeon
and that's a very high paying job.
And plus, that was just a place that the wizards
all own anyway, so he gets to-
Oh, that's true.
But I mean, even-
He gets to stay there rent free.
Right.
But even before that, he was a-
Who pays taxes on that?
Magic.
I forgot about magic.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
The cop-out, magic.
I'm just like, I don't understand where the
paychecks come from for anyone like War Machine
or Black Widow.
Is Ant-Man, does Scott Lang just kind of work
for Hank Pym?
Is that...?
He's got the security system.
The security company, right?
He has a business.
Oh, right.
That's right.
He has a business.
He's a small business owner.
That's right.
He's a small business owner, so he has a legit
way to make a living.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Because money was a central focus in the first
Ant-Man.
He was a burglar.
So he steals money.
Right.
Because he had gone to jail for some huge
heist, right, and then he was like, I want
to keep stealing to support my family.
Yeah.
And so when you make that a prime concern
of your story, you can have some fun explaining
how and why he needs and gets money.
But yeah, it's still...
I have my own theories, right, because we
started talking-
So what are those theories, Brian?
I'm so glad that you asked.
We started talking about this because of Falcon
and the Winter Soldier.
And then I got to thinking, well, what about
WandaVision?
Right.
So in Infinity War, we see that Wanda and
Vision are hanging out in Edinburgh, Scotland
in some very fancy looking apartment or hotel.
Who's paying for that?
I don't know.
Then at the end of WandaVision, spoilers,
we find out that there was a deed to a house
owned by Wanda, and it literally said on the
deed, Vision.
So legally, this robot owned this land that
they somehow bought and paid for and were
going to build a house on.
So this raises a lot of questions because
Vision doesn't...
Yes?
I have one thing.
So you're talking about the scene in WandaVision
where they flash back to the, what is grief
but not love persevering.
That was not at a fancy hotel, that was the
Avenger's headquarters.
She says that, she's like-
Well, no, no, no, no, no.
Right, right, right.
No.
Yes, you are correct.
So she's in a very-
This is at the beginning of Infinity War.
I'm talking about at the beginning of Infinity
War.
That's right.
They're in Scotland just hanging out.
Yeah.
Right.
They're just in some-
She shows up and she figures out the Vision
has learned how to turn himself into Paul
Bettany, which is awesome.
Right.
A great power.
It seemed to work out well for both of them.
It would, man.
But so it raises the question how does this
robot who is not a person, how does he have
money to go in on a house with Wanda Maximoff
who also doesn't have a job.
And I know-
If we're just talking in terms of universe
building, I would say that this is the beginning
of a giant MCU real estate bubble crash.
This is another 2008 all over again where
what happens is the banks start giving out
loans to beings that are not necessarily going
to be considered legally human in the future.
They know that there's going to be a court
case coming up, and then they've got their
people behind the scenes pushing for it.
You know what, man?
I mean, are synthezoids really human beings?
He's 90% vibranium.
I mean, I don't know about you, I'm not.
So could he even really own the house that
he's been paying for this entire time?
This feels like a scam.
Right.
And also, what person is like, oh, I'll definitely
sell a house to you, robot man.
I mean, this helps to explain why they wouldn't
give Falcon a loan after the blip.
Right.
Because that house is bought pre-blip and
then everyone goes away and they're like,
we're not just giving out houses to Avengers
anymore.
But, but, but, but, but, but this raises the
question, so how are they paying for this
thing in the first place?
How are they even getting these loans?
Where's the down payment coming from?
And the only thing I could think of, the only
way that I think that Wanda Maximoff and the
Vision make money is through mind control.
They don't do any jobs.
Yeah, that makes perfect sense.
They don't do any work for goods or services
outside of being superheroes.
And we know now that Stark doesn't pay them.
So they must go to, when they need sweaters,
they go to JCPenney, they take what they want
and they do a little Jedi mind trick, you
don't need to see my credit card.
And then they leave.
Ultimately, you got Vision, he's messing with
bank accounts digitally.
I mean, that's a small and untraceable crime,
but-
He's a computer.
... at the same time, morally, how do we justify
this?
What crime is justifiable for a superhero
to commit?
There's a whole book to be written here you
guys.
It's not going to be interesting-
Steal bread to feed your family.
... or readable and nobody's going to buy
it, but I think it's a really good book.
You can steal bread to feed your family, that's
justifiable, but what if instead of bread,
your family needs a really fancy hotel in
Scotland to just not be an Avenger.
Just for a weekend.
Or to buy a house in New Jersey.
Sorry, New Jersey, we stole this land.
Who owned that parcel of land?
They lost all that money because Wanda did
her little whoop, the thing that she did.
The mind control thing.
Mind control.
Vision too can unlock and re-lock your memories
in your brain apparently.
So straight up mind control, that's-
Brian, I love that you've cast this robot
god of the franchise.
As in just trying to get by.
Just trying to get by, baby.
Just needs that loaf of bread/hotel room for
his loved ones.
Just this bulletproof man who can walk through
any wall on the planet.
He's just trying to get by.
What is love if not stealing-
Mind control.
... a plot of land in New Jersey through mind
control persevering.
Yeah.
It's pretty sad when you think about it.
Were they sneaking into those hotel rooms?
Is that what was happening?
I think they went to the front desk and they
were like, you have a reservation for Wanda
Maximoff and the Vision.
Right.
And they're like, yes, because they did mind
control.
There's no other explanation.
And also, the hotel in Scotland, as hotels
are want to do, would be like, can I see your
passport?
And they'd be like, no, because we're not
real people.
So they would have to use mind control.
I'm a former terrorist, he's a robot, we're
kind of on the run.
Sokovia Accords, I don't know.
Things went wrong.
Yada, yada, yada, yada.
Anyway, can we have a master suite?
Yeah.
Don't worry.
And then they use a fake name to check in
just to kind of spice it up a little bit extra.
It's fun, man.
Yeah.
So that's my answer to that question.
That's horrifying.
Thanks for joining us.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode.